on a tous eu un premier déclic qui nous
a éveillé alors ça peut être un livre un
film une rencontre où une chanson moi
mon déclic ont été les chansons engagées
de michael jackson notamment celle sur
la famine en afrique
alors elles ont été mon déclic pour deux
raisons tout d'abord quand je les ai
découvertes tête haute comme trois
pommes
j'avais trois quatre ans donc tous ses
clips in the world we are the world où
étaient les premières images qui m'ont
bouleversé je regardais pas encore des
documentaires et je regardais encore
moins les jt quand j'avais 3 4 ans et
les deuxième raison c'est que tous ces
chanteurs engagés montré qu'on pouvait
dédiée du temps et de l'énergie pour une
cause afin d'aider les plus vulnérables
c'est comme ça que j'ai grandi avec
cette idée et ses refrains notamment
jusqu'à 26 ans ou là je me suis dit que
j'avais envie d'agir et j'avais moi
aussi envie du passé du clip à la
réalité
j'étais frustré j'étais obstiné par ces
images elles ne bouleversait j'avais
envie d'être moi aussi en immersion au
coeur de l'humanité
alors qu'est ce que j'ai fait et bien 26
ans j'ai tout quitté
j'étais journaliste sur une chaîne télé
généraliste j'ai tout quitté j'ai décidé
d'aligner mon envie sur des sujets qui
m'animait et donc du coup naturellement
je me suis tourné vers l'humanitaire
j'avais décidé de tendre mon micro comme
ces chanteurs ou ces humanitaires qui
voulait changer le monde et je me suis
retrouvé quelques mois plus tard dans un
camp de réfugiés au bangladesh
et si je vous en parle c'est parce que
là j'avais tout juste 26 ans et je
commençais à tim kring au stade de boxe
parce que deux grands événements majeurs
sont arrivées dans ma vie pile à ce
moment là alors le premier événement ça
a été la découverte d'un camp de
réfugiés
et pas des moindres entre guillemets
j'étais immergé avec l'héroïne gars qui
connaît les rohingya dans la salle
depuis 1982 ce sont plus d'un million de
personnes qui n'ont pas de carte
d'identité pas de sécurité ils ont rien
du tout donc imaginer le bouleversement
émotionnel et puis la deuxième c'était
mon opération du coeur
quelques semaines après mon retour du
bangladesh car il ya un lien entre la
mission humanitaire et mon opération du
coeur la veille de mon départ je fais un
an banal check up médical avant de
rejoindre les équipes d'action contre la
faim sur le terrain et là on entend un
souffle au coeur je me dis bon ok j'ai
un souffle au coeur est alors de retour
de mission je veux voir un cardiologue
pour la première fois de ma vie
et là on m'annonce que c'est plus qu'un
souffle au coeur c'est entre ou une
malformation cardiaque congénitale
je n'ai souffler mais 27 bouger et donc
pendant 27 ans j'ai grandi avec un trou
dans le coeur est là dix jours plus tard
on m'a posé ça assez mon bijou de coeur
est ce que j'avais pas entre les deux
oreillettes est ce qui a comblé mon trou
de 3 cm donc j'étais
pas du tout le cas du reste du monde
donc forcément après ces deux grands
bouleversements majeurs dans ma vie j'ai
décidé en tant que journaliste de tendre
mon micro vers celles et ceux qui comme
ses chanteurs ou ces humanitaires
voulait changer le monde
j'ai décidé d'aligner mon métier avec
mes émotions et de créer de l'impact
aussi créé de l'impact entre que
journaliste mais aussi en tant que femme
ou citoyenne je fais maintenant du
journalisme de solutions c'est à dire
que je les vends uniquement les
personnes qui veulent changer le monde
comme ces chanteurs ils trouvent des
solutions pour vivre dans un monde plus
juste plus égalitaire plus propre et
plus durable
alors cette changemakers sait qui c'est
qui ces acteurs du changement
c'est qui ce porteur de solutions eh
bien on ce sont des célébrités ou des
anonymes
ce sont des chanteurs engagés ce sont
des humanitaires ou même des chirurgiens
cardiaques mais également des
entrepreneurs sociaux ou encore des
protecteurs de l'environnement
ils ont tous un point commun ils veulent
tous changer le monde
et en parlant d'environnement qu'est ce
que vous entendez
la forêt c'est ya quelques mois et
l'amazone il était en amazonie
colombienne l'amazone hisser la deuxième
plus grande forêt du monde c'est notre
poumon vert c'est la vie ce sont plus de
15 mille espèces endémiques et moi
j'entends la vie notamment à la nuit
tombante c'est exactement le bruit qu'on
entende la forêt se réveille mais dans
cette forêt ya aussi des hommes des
femmes des enfants on les appelait les
peuples des forêts ces communautés qu'on
appelle indigènes qui vivent 2 et dans
la forêt alors pour eux d'ailleurs comme
pour nous c'est valable également pour
nous européens occidentaux l'arbre c'est
l'essence même de la vie
alors eux ils s'en servent notamment
pour leurs habitations pour faire des
poux la junte dans la forêt pour faire
leurs pirogues pour faire de la tenture
de leurs vêtements de leur artisanat et
s'en servent pour se nourrir
également pour se soigner mais vous le
savez quand il ya des arbres il y a
également la déforestation pour
plusieurs raisons l'élevage bovin la
culture de soja ou encore des produits
milly pollueurs et donc ce sont autant
de dangers pour tous ces peuples
indigènes
ces communautés qui vivent de la forêt
c'est en danger pour l'heure pour eux
mêmes pour leurs cultures
traditionnelles et donc mais en tant que
journaliste je me pose la question face
à cette problématique de la
déforestation les verts qui vais-je
pouvoir tendre mon micro qui vais-je
pouvoir inspirer qui vais à qui vais-je
pouvoir faire naître des vocations
quelle est la solution quelle innovation
face à cette problématique
alors si j'étais devant un parterre
d'indiens je vous parlerai d'une
personne qui fait de l'agriculture
raisonnée en amazonie il se trouve que
vous n'êtes pas des indiens qui vivent
en amazonie enfin je ne pense pas
alors comme je suis devant un public
européen de consommateurs et d'acteurs
économiques européens j'essaie à mon
échelle de vous parler de sujets de
vocation de parcours aux idées de
solutions qui peuvent vous inspirer et
peut-être faire naître des vocations
chez vous par exemple comme maison du
monde et notamment sa fondation maison
du monde
qu'est-ce qu'elle fait cette fondation
elle soutient des projets de protection
de l'environnement comme des
associations comme là où j'étais
qu'ils s'appellent forest ever qui
consiste à faire de l'arbre foresterie
notamment dans des populations indigènes
comme la cet été avec l'éthique ou n'a
donc faire de l'agroforesterie c'est
pour le bon maintien de leur communauté
avec ses arbres
comme je vous ai dit ils peuvent
s'habiller faire de la tête de
l'artisanat se soigner et se nourrir et
construire tous leurs villages donc là
on parle carrément d'entreprise à
vocation économique qui peuvent
justement réparer leurs actions bureau
de mental en plantant des arbres là où
ils peuvent être extrêmement utile avis
à tous les futurs chefs d'entreprise ici
dans cette avec vous parler de mon
deuxième ken baker
j'aimerais savoir dans cette salle en
levant la main qui a au nom planter un
arbre cette semaine
cette bravo vous avez pris tous leurs
mains si j'en ai planté que deux pour le
moment et qu'on l'ait fait possible et
bien c'est mon deuxième challenge mais
coeur et kosyam en faisant des
recherches sur internet
vous contribuez à verdir la planète en
plus ça rime et cozien c'est le moteur
de recherche qui plantent des arbres
alors par exemple avec eux j'ai pu le
voir en ethiopie alors en ethiopie ont
planté des arbres non pas pour soutenir
des communautés indigènes
mais pour soutenir les populations
rurales notamment les femmes qui gèrent
tout le village est donc là bas j'ai pu
voir l'impact des arbres sur ces
communautés sur ces populations planter
un arbre par exemple d'où sa structure
le sol ça fait revivre la biodiversité
mais ça apporte de l'eau et quand on a
de l'eau eh bien on a on peut faire de
la culture canton de la culture on peut
vivre de ses ressources avec ses
ressources vivrières
mais également voir des revenus
supplémentaires et faire vivre sa
famille et même parfois quand il y à de
l'eau ça profite à qui
aux petites filles qu'il ne passe plus
des heures aller chercher de l'eau et à
la place elles peuvent aller à l'école
donc ça peut également permettre en
plantant un arbre effet en direct
données de l'éducation à la jeunesse
donc là par exemple je vous ai dit
rapidement deux exemples qui peuvent
peut-être vous inspirez que vous pouvez
faire en un clic pour avoir un impact à
défaut de savoir chanter un impact
positif sur notre planète sur notre
biodiversité sur l'humanité avec taux
simple code d'européens
alors est-ce qu'on peut revenir à à 20
alors pour changer le monde on l'a vu il
ya les entreprises il ya les fondations
il y a également vous il y a également
aux enfants où vous futurs enfants
je crois que c'est moins d'élan qui
disait que l'éducation pour changer le
monde était la meilleure arme
alors laissez moi vous parler de ma
dernière petite gare hier juste avant un
bas je vous présente à va 4 ans et demi
niçoise alors je lui ai tendu le micro
il ya quelques semaines je crois que
c'était le 16 mars pour la marche du
siècle
et à votre avis qu'est ce que m'a dit
avant on était à nice elle m'a dit
qu'elle en avait marre que l'on jette
notamment les adultes les papiers par
terre
et à votre avis
pourquoi elle en a marre que l'on jette
les papiers par terre parce qu'à 20 à
vis près de la mer elle voit que ces
déchets vont dans la mer et la fin ils
vont dans le coeur des animaux et des
poissons
eh bien ces quelques minutes des changes
ont eu plus de 50000 vu en quelques
jours sur les réseaux sociaux
imaginez si ces cinquante mille
personnes arrêtent de jeter des papiers
par terre ça pourrait déjà être un
effort supplémentaire avoir un petit
impact sur nos océans qui en ont besoin
car l'on déverse déjà plus de 8 millions
de tonnes de déchets chaque année
j'aimerais terminer fait y'a pas d'âge
pour inspirer mais j'aimerais surtout
terminé pour vous dire comment j'ai fait
moi à mon échelle pour essayer un jour
de thinking that the box et surtout de
créer mon métier sur mesure
mon métier passion et bien c'est l'amour
c'est l'amour des lots de l'autre des
autres c'est l'amour du vivant tellement
de l'environnement de nos forêts de nos
océans de nos peuples
l'amour de nos différences à 6 de notre
diversité est ce également l'amour que
j'ai vu ce matin là dans le regard de
havas alors pour changer le monde
laissez vous guider par votre coeur même
quand celui-ci et rafistolé merci
[Applaudissements]